Normally when we want to use Claude
Code, we have to do so in a chat window
like this on our local machine, or we
could obviously pull up the terminal,
type in Claude, and then access it this
way. But now we're able to type in this
command, Claude remote dash control, and
that basically gives us this QR code,
which we can use to remote into this
from our phone or anywhere else. So if I
go ahead and scan this QR code right
here, it opens up my remote control
session of my Herc 2.0 project. And so
what I can do is shoot off this message
in this session that says run a comment
analysis from my YouTube videos and ID8
new topics. And this is actually going
to do it really, really well because in
this project, my Herc 2 kind of personal
assistant, it's got these different
agents, it's got these different skills,
and it can actually use all of these
from my phone. So here you can see it
says, "Let me kick off the idea mining
process. I'll check the data freshness
first, and then I'll spin up those
agents in parallel." It has context on
my business, my current priorities, what
I'm working on, and it's going to make
this way better. So I basically now have
Claude Code in my pocket. It's doing the
exact same things on here as you can
see, and I could go off to lunch, I
could go to the gym, and I could still
keep working and checking in on my
Claude Code.
Okay, so that just finished up. It ran a
YouTube analyzer agent and my research
agent, and now we have a full brief for
February 25th with top video ideas. As
you can see, it's going through what's
trending, but it's also looking at my
comments. What else is cool is if I
close out of this terminal here, even
though this is still running, and I go
to my past conversations, you can see
this is exactly what I just triggered
from my phone, and I can now pick up the
conversation over here, and then I can
jump back over to my phone, and I can
just keep working all the time, as long
as I'm able to maintain an internet
connection. So this is all thanks to
Claude Code's new feature, the remote
control. So that's exactly what I'm
going to be talking to you guys about
today, showing you how to set it up,
going over some things you need to know,
and why this is exciting. So my one
sentence overview here is that you start
a coding task on your computer, and
you're kind of desk bound, but then
using the remote control, you can
control it from anywhere. You could be
having lunch, having a cup of coffee,
going on a walk, and all of your
different agents can be running for you.
The work keeps going. And what's so
great about this is that the setup
literally could not be simpler. You type
a command, you scan a code, and then
you're connected. So, heading over to
the official CloudCode docs right here
for the new remote control, it says that
you're able to continue a local
CloudCode session from your phone,
tablet, or any browser. When you start
this session, Cloud stays running
locally, so nothing ever moves to the
cloud. So, like I mentioned in the demo,
I was working in this local project, so
I had access to all of his contacts and
all of these skills and rules. And you
can work from both services at once. The
entire conversation stays synced. The
requirements are you have to have a pro
or max plan. You can't use an API key,
and then all you have to do pretty much
is you run Cloud, and you log in, and
then you just have to give that
workspace trust. And then if you're
already in an existing session, you just
do  remote control. And if you
want to start a new session, you just do
Cloud remote-control, like you guys saw
in my demo. So, you guys could search
more through these docs. It'll explain
pretty much everything about this, but
like I said, it's super super simple.
It's literally just these four steps,
and you're all set. Now, one thing to
keep in mind is the session URL. Don't
put that on the internet. Don't show
that to people, or the QR code. So, if I
was to open up a new terminal, and I
wanted to just go ahead and do a Cloud
remote control, you guys can see that we
get right here this actual URL. And I
could hit space if I want the QR code,
but this URL works, too. So, if I follow
this link, this will basically open this
up in my web browser right here on my
desktop, or I could put this in my
phone, and then I'd be able to connect
to the remote control session. As you
can see, here's all the ones I was doing
during testing, and we still have some
active sessions right here. But the
point is anyone could go to this link,
and then control your local files. So,
just don't give that to people. Now, I
will say I tried logging in from like a
different Cloud account with a different
email, and it was taking a long time to
connect, and I I'm not convinced it
would actually let me in, but I would
still just say don't share that that
But you just need to be mindful of what
sessions you have open. As you can see
if they're disconnected, it won't let
you chat, but if they're connected, you
can see that they still technically
could access stuff. Okay, so some real
quick things to know, or maybe just to
hammer home. The first one would be if
you're having trouble, then try to
update things. Try to update your Cloud
Code or the app on your phone, or maybe
some settings on your computer. Just try
to update some things before you assume
the worst has happened. The first
question I wanted to address, which we
already kind of covered, is that is this
running in the cloud? No. Your phone is
just a window to what's actually
happening locally, which is different
from Cloud Code on the web, which is
running on Anthropic servers. But of
course, the AI models are connecting to
Anthropic service through API. But the
files and everything like that, that is
still all local. Nano Banana had a
really hard time here spelling
Anthropic, as you can see.
But I got it right right there, so I
don't know. Question two is what has to
stay on? So, you have to maintain
internet connection. If you don't have
connection for like 10 minutes, I think
that's when you get disconnected. Your
laptop or desktop needs to stay on. I
think sleep is okay, but it has to stay
on. And the terminal has to stay open.
Meaning if you wanted to go away for
like a couple hours, you might be fine.
You might just want to change the
settings on your laptop so it doesn't
shut off. But if you wanted to go away
for like a week, which this product
definitely isn't built for that, you
would also have to make sure that things
aren't getting updated and automatically
restarting and that your internet
connection's going to be good, stuff
like that. Now, because of that,
unfortunately, we can only start new
sessions for remote control from our
terminal. If you're away from your
computer and there's not a session
running, you couldn't start a new one.
If your computer falls asleep, the
session dies. If there's no terminal
running locally, there's nothing that
your phone or the remote can actually
connect to. And that's what I would
really love to see next. Obviously,
there are some ways that you can sort of
Frankenstein your solution to wrap up
Cloud Code so you can access it anywhere
and start up conversations anywhere. But
I would love to see this native, and
that is really what I hope comes soon.
The next question is who can use this,
which is also pretty much all this is
covered in the docs. But you have to be
on the Pro or Max plan. So, the Pro is
the around 20 bucks a month, the Max is
either 100 or 200. And you can't be on a
team or enterprise plan yet. I'm sure
it'll come soon, but right now it has to
be personal plan, and of course you
cannot authenticate through APIs. And
finally, I just wanted to say this one
more time, do not show people the QR
code or the session URL unless that
session has been killed already. Because
if you can just click on a link and
access all your local files, then so can
anyone else that has that link. Because
if you remember, there wasn't two-factor
authentication, there wasn't a password.
We basically just opened it up. Now, I
will say I tried logging in from like a
different Claude account with a
different email, and it was taking a
long time to connect, and I I'm not
convinced it would actually let me in,
but I would still just say don't share
that URL. And I wanted to end off this
video just by talking about like why is
this exciting and kind of what's going
on with Anthropic. So, I found this
article right here that I thought had
some cool stats, and I just pulled out a
few of the ones that I thought were kind
of cool to highlight, but I'll link the
full article in the description.
The $2.5 billion agent, the launch of
remote control serves as an escalation
force in what has become a dominant
business for Anthropic. Claude code has
now hit in just basically a year, $2.5
billion annualized run rate, which has
more than doubled since the start of
this year. So, you know, in the past 2
months. They're currently having their
ChatGPT moment, surging to 29 million
daily installs within Visual Studio
Code. So, super cool. And this statistic
might actually feel fake, but moving
towards everything sort of being vibe
coded, and all the stuff I've heard
about Anthropic engineers not really
coding anymore, and having a ton of code
reviewer agents as well that are
catching things that humans are missing.
But apparently we're entering this era
where AI tools are writing roughly 41%
of all code. And I imagine over the next
few months that will definitely be able
to bump over 50% of code being written
by AI. And obviously we've seen this all
over with how quick POCs and startups
and, you know, different products all
being written with AI coding tools.
Anyways, I know it was a quick one, but
I just wanted to show you guys how this
kind of stuff works and what I thought
about it. If you love nerding out about
this kind of stuff, then definitely
check out my plus group. The link for
this is down in the description. We've
got over 3,000 members who are building
with AI every day, building businesses
with AI, and it's a great place to be if
you have similar goals. So, I'd love to
see you guys in this community, but
that's going to do it for today. If you
enjoyed the video or you learned
something new, please give it a like.
Definitely helps me out a ton. And as
always, I appreciate you guys making it
to the end of the video. I will see you
on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.